what is going on everybody welcome to
another Python tutorial video series
this series is going to be talking about
pie QT with Python so PI QT is a wrapper
around the Qt framework which is a
framework for creating gooeys we're
going to be using the Qt 4 framework
there are two frameworks there's QT for
QT v QT 5 is a slightly newer but it
comes with a lot more dependencies and
it also has a slightly different
licensing kind of process and QT 4 does
QT 4 is much simpler much more
black-and-white and vanilla to use so
therefore I think it would be best to go
ahead and use QT 4 so QT how does it
differ from say tkinter or WX python
because all of these are GUI development
frameworks so why should we use PI QT or
learn another framework a lot of its
going to come down to user preference or
at least developer preference and QT is
a little more updated I would say back
when maybe a few years ago I wouldn't
have really said such a thing but maybe
even WX Python would have come first
because they were constantly putting
updates out but now I would say QT is by
far the most up-to-date framework for
creating Windows and it's going to look
the best on a lot of systems so this is
going to be the most cross-platform
compatible GUI that you're going to find
pretty much and you can you can easily
change the style so like with tkinter
you can really only change to like one
style until you need to like you have to
code the style completely and that takes
a lot of code so with QT it comes with a
bunch of styles but it also comes with a
lot of really intuitive widgets that
just make sense to have pre built in so
obviously there's a lot of stuff with QT
or any frameworks that they can't
envision that you want to do but QT
comes pretty well packed with a lot of
widgets and a lot of widgets that are
going to be cross-platform and makes
sense per operating system that you use
it on
so anyways now that I've sort of sold
you on QT for the best thing to do is
really just try them out try out all the
frameworks see what suits you best
because they're all a little different
and most importantly to develop with
them is a little different and honestly
QT for so far for like me if you're
going to make a big application
my experience with QT is so far has been
really good actually I like them more
than I really like to tkinter initially
but tkinter makes it pretty hard to make
a large application whereas QT honestly
QT makes it pretty darn simple so let's
go ahead and just jump in so the first
thing you're going to have to do is
actually acquire QT so to do that you're
going to come to riverbank computing the
parent company and you're going to want
to go to this link basically software
pie cutie and download now if you're on
Windows that's what you want to do
pretty much you come down here and
download the Installer that suits you
okay so this would be QT four point
eight point six for Windows 64 and then
this would be for one is 32 now if
you're not on Windows if you're on Mac
or Linux you should be able to get by
with a simple sudo apt-get install
python - - QT for that is all you should
have to run and that should install QT 4
for you once you have those things drink
your coffee and you're ready to move on
so you're gonna pretty much always have
the couple things you're gonna pretty
much always import sis and you're almost
always actually yeah yeah there's some
scenarios where you might not import the
GUI aspect but anyway from PI QT for
import QT GUI now this note the caps
here they're kind of confusing
especially GUI I want to capitalize
everything in GUI but no it's just the
capital G uh they followed pep 8 past
the whole caps thing anyways pie QT for
import QT GUI so so this is like the
basically QT GUI is all
the major GUI aspects there's also QT
core which will use kind of not too long
and in the future and then those are the
two major ones that you're pretty much
always going to use but there are other
ones so QT comes with things like QT
opengl for including opengl which is
really cool of course you can always
include opengl in your WX Python your
tkinter so all you fanboys don't need to
jump out at me but it's a little easier
into n QT so you can do that there's QT
XML QT SVG so XML for XML obviously SVG
support vector graphics QT SQL QT
networking and the list goes on so
there's a lot of kind of like built-in
handling for these sorts of things now
of course again like with QT SQL do you
have to use QT SQL for your SQL handling
no but it's going to be a little more
useful
so anyways moving on you're gonna
basically I always have these two
imports for sure if you're making GUI is
surely you're going to use the GUI
anyway but I can envision some people
might just happen to really like I don't
know
QT Network you like the handling of it
so maybe you use QT Network with
something else
I don't know so anyway you're gonna have
those two imports now in your
application your GUI whatever you're
always going to have the same kind of
three major aspects first you're going
to have some sort of app definition so
the whole application so app equals
cutie GUI dot Q application and then
here we're going to pass sis Arg V now
if you're not familiar with sis dark V
you can come to Python program internet
start learning go to search type in sis
and here's what you want and basically
what it's going to let you do is Arg fee
is going to allow you when you could
call this application from the command
line and you could pass arguments via
the command line now you don't have to
put assist our dark V here but you have
to put something you can't go home but
you can't stay here anyway you can put
in here empty list or something like
that
and then you don't have to
put anything there you'll see some
people do that but just already makes
the most sense to put there anyway but
some people are just like really adamant
about not putting sister hungry so I'll
do this instead so anyway you do that
next you're going to have something that
defines the GUI the window whatever it
is so we're going to go ahead and say
for now let's say window equals QT GUI Q
widget now one thing that I do like that
pie QT has done for us is generally when
you're referencing any sort of QT class
they're going to go ahead and throw a
capital Q in front of it so you can look
at your code really quick and no wait is
that my method or is that qts method you
look at it and you'll just know because
of the queue pretty fast and they do
that for a lot of things so I really do
appreciate that from PI Q T so it was
that's just a quick widget and then
finally you're going to always have
window dot show so you're always going
to have a dot show to your application
otherwise what happens is that
everything is created in memory and then
as soon as you call it to show then it
shows because that's how graphics work
graphics are all created kind of in the
background and then when you finally
wanted to show you show because graphics
take the most memory and it just makes
sense to build it first in the
background and then bring it up
so that's your application and that's
basically you're always going to use
this sort of structure now of course
there's going to be a lot more involved
as we go down the road but for now this
is a basic window so let's go ahead and
save and run that with F 500 blind
anyway from PI QT for import QT GUI
drink more coffee and here you have your
basic window now we've just done this in
three lines but really more than three
lines went into this so this window can
be resized it looks like a window it
looks the same as and you can bring this
window over it kind of follows that same
kind of see-through
look it's got the same buttons here for
anyone who's curious this is for team
viewers so you probably don't have that
button so don't feel like
you're you're falling behind because you
don't have that button there's window
resizes it's even got this little shadow
it maximizes it d-max it maximizes I'm
sure you call that and most importantly
it can exit out so we already have all
these little handling features that we
didn't have to code it all for ourselves
now the other thing I'm going to show
really quick before we move on to the
next video is the title to your window
and then also some size and starting
point so the once you've defined your
window you've got this nice window
object what we can do is we can go
window to set geometry and you can say
the set geometry takes four parameters
it's the starting point
so starting x starting Y and then the
dimensions so the x and y or the width
and the height now like most GUI
applications the starting points are
really up here so 0 0 is always like top
left most GUI applications are like that
like key V is an example of one that's
from the bottom left so that's really
annoying for me cuz I'm used to like
everything top left but if you work with
like HTML or anything else or all the
other GUI frameworks it's top left
anyway so set geometry we're going to
have it's starting point 50/50 and then
we'll say the window is 500 pixels wide
and 300 pixels tall the other thing we
can do really simply is window set
window title and then you can pass in
whatever window title you want we'll
call this pie QT Tut's so let's go ahead
and say we run that one that comes up
and here you have a nice window it
followed our rules about banging being
500 wide 300 tall and it did start at 50
50 now one thing I will just mention is
you can start a window at zero zero zero
zero is going to show us a little bit
more of a fundamental thing about this
window so as you can see my window is
off the screen I film in 1080p
it's my full monitor at least for this
monitor but I have a monitor that sits
over here and a monitor that sits up
here so above this window so there's one
to the left
actually there's one to the right to and
one above so this window didn't really
appear on this screen it's on three
total screens so if you just had one
went one monitor chances are it probably
appeared like this but it tried to go up
here but your operating system was like
tats silly so it stuffed it down here
for you because it has a nice little
handling for stupid choices so what
happened there well zero zero what is
that in reference to well like I was
saying you've got application and then
you've got a window and you might also
hear this generally referred to as
you've got a frame and then you've got a
window so the frame is what's around the
window and then you've got the actual
window which starts here and that's why
when we said started at zero zero this
point was at zero zero not like this
fake corner that should be here without
the rounded edges so keep that in mind
it wouldn't matter you could do zero
zero all day if you want but it will
show up off screen for some users so
that's kind of annoying sometimes anyway
that's that with this simple application
normally it's going to be you're going
to be using object when you're
programming off classes and all this and
we really did use object-oriented
programming you just didn't see it
yourself but there's a lot of basically
everything here is an object and we're
modifying the object here so anyway
that's we're going to get into in the
next video is kind of converting this to
the sort of structure that you're going
to tend to use when creating an
application so that's what you guys have
to look forward to if you have any
questions or comments up to this point
please feel free to leave them below
otherwise as always thanks for watching
thanks for all the support and
subscriptions until next time